lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explicar la idea de lo que es una
ecuación lineal y vamos a ver algunos
ejemplos de ecuaciones lineales por
ejemplo la ecuación de igual a 2x menos
3 es una ecuación lineal porque las
llamamos así porque si tomamos todos los
padres xy que es satisfacer esta
ecuación y los gráfica nos aquí en el
plano coordenada tendríamos una línea y
es por eso que se llama ecuación y miel
de hecho vamos a calcular varios de
estos pares ordenados que son solución a
esta ecuación lineal y después veremos
que en realidad al graficar los forman
una línea elijamos algunos valores de x
que no sean sencillos de calcular los
valores de y veamos cuando x es igual a
0 a que se dé igual pues 2 por x que es
0 2 por 0 0 lleva a ser igual a menos 3
vamos a graficar ese punto en el plano
coordenada cuando x es cero
y es igual a menos 3 aquí se encuentra
este punto ahora si x fuera igual a 1
lleva a ser igual a 2 por 1 2 2 - 3 - 1
vamos a graficar este punto x 1 y menos
1 x 1 y menos uno que está aquí ahora si
x es igual a 2 2 por 244 menos 3 1
vamos a graficar el punto x2 si uno está
aquí y yo espero que ustedes puedan ver
que si yo continúo graficando puntos y
de hecho los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de graficar algunos
puntos más por su cuenta por ejemplo con
x igual a 3 o con x igual a menos 1 si
los grafican verán que forman parte de
esta línea de hecho vamos a unir los
puntos para que vean qué línea se forma
voy a agarrar mi herramienta para
dibujar líneas y voy a unir este punto
con este y con éste y lo voy a extender
y lo mismo de este otro lado para que
vean qué línea se forma
esta línea que acabo de graficar de
hecho es la gráfica de la función que
igual a 2 x 3 aquí están todos los
puntos de pares ordenados que satisfacen
esta ecuación y que sea ustedes me digan
a ver espera un momento tú solo en
contraste tres puntos como es que tienes
una línea bueno yo aquí use valores
enteros para x pero ustedes pueden usar
cualquier valor entre ellos y de hecho
es un concepto genial cualquier valor de
x que usemos aquí para encontrar su
correspondiente valor de iu estará en
esta línea por ejemplo digamos que x es
menos punto 5
en los puntos 5 y si vemos la línea
tenemos que parece ser menos 4 vamos a
verificarlo si x es igual menos punto 5
que lo pongo como una fracción menos un
medio a que va a ser igual que 2 x menos
un medio va a ser igual a menos 1 - 1 -
3 va a ser igual a menos 4 lo que es
correcto como lo vimos aquí en la
gráfica así que podemos tener cualquier
valor de x y por cada valor de x el
respectivo valor en g va a estar en esta
línea así que cualquier punto en esta
línea va a ser solución de esta ecuación
por ejemplo no sé este punto de aquí es
solución de esta ecuación este punto de
acá también es una solución a esta
ecuación lineal pero este punto de acá
no es solución de esta ecuación si x es
igual a 5 lo evaluamos aquí 5 por 2 10
10 menos 3 es igual a 7 y aquí vemos que
este 3 que corresponde a la coordenadas
de este punto no es una solución de este
y pues vemos que no coincide en la línea
el valor x 5 nos da 7 en la línea que es
este de aquí que está encima de esta
línea el punto 57 satisface esta
ecuación esta ecuación lineal por eso se
llama así lineal ya que si tomamos todos
los padres xy que satisfacen esta
ecuación y los gráfica moss nos van a
dar siempre una línea esta no es la
única manera en la que podemos escribir
una ecuación lineal por ejemplo la
ecuación
4 x menos 3 e igual a 12 también es una
ecuación lineal si graficar hemos los
valores x
de esta ecuación también tendríamos una
línea por ejemplo si x es igual a 0 este
término desaparece y me queda menos 3 y
igual a 12 por lo que va a ser igual a
menos 12 entre 3 es igual a menos 4x por
0 es igual a 0 tenemos menos 3 x menos 4
esto va a ser igual a 2 así que esto es
correcto si yo fuera igual a 0
tendríamos que este término se cancela y
nos quedan 4 x igual a 12 x sería igual
a 12 entre 4 sería igual a 3 positivo
por lo que tendríamos el punto cero coma
menos 40 menos 4 aquí y el punto 30
y esta línea va a lucir algo así uso mi
herramienta de dibujo
más o menos
por aquí
por acá nuevamente todos los pares xx
satisfacen esta ecuación se van a
encontrar dentro de esta línea y bueno a
lo mejor ustedes me pueden preguntar
cualquier ecuación es una ecuación
lineal pues la respuesta es no veamos
algunos ejemplos de ecuaciones no
lineales entonces tendremos ejemplos de
ecuaciones
lineales
por ejemplo
la ecuación
ye igual a equis cuadrada y gráfica mos
esto verán que nos da una curva otra
ecuación no lineal podría ser
x x es igual a 12 que tampoco sería
lineal una ecuación más podría ser un 5
entre x más ye igual a 10 que tampoco es
una línea los invito a que traten de
gráficas estas ecuaciones para que vean
que no forman una línea pero ahora que
vimos las ecuaciones lineales y las no
lineales tratemos de encontrar una
definición para ecuaciones lineales
una forma de pensar en esto es que si la
ecuación al graficar todos los valores
que la satisfacen forman una línea
entonces es una ecuación lineal y de
hecho de ahí viene la palabra lineal en
su nombre otra forma de pensar en ello
es una ecuación en la que cada término
va a ser ya sea una constante por
ejemplo este 12 o este menos 3 o va a
ser una constante que multiplica a una
de las variables por ejemplo este 2 x el
2 es una constante multiplicada por x a
la primera potencia y esta es la
variable y elevada a la primera potencia
no estamos dividiendo las xy las 'íes'
como aquí tampoco tenemos x hoy es
elevadas a alguna potencia al cuadrado
al cubo o a la potencia 15 y tampoco
multiplicamos las equis cellay es como
tenemos aquí así que si todos los
términos de la ecuación en ambos lados
de la igualdad
ya sea una constante o una constante que
multiplica una variable y estas
variables están elevadas a la primera
potencia y no se multiplican entre sí
entonces tenemos una ecuación lineal